okay if we want to take advantage of
having data to figure out whether a
particular policy has succeeded or
failed we need two things or I guess you
could say we need at least two things we
need time to allow that policy to either
succeed or fail or maybe do neither but
we also need to know what to measure
right just having data isn't useful
unless we know what are we looking for
what would be a sign that a policy has
succeeded or failed we can now apply
this a sort of paradigm this
infrastructure to look at Donald Trump's
tax cuts and I say that with some
reservation because it wasn't actually a
tax cut for everyone and even some of
the people who did get a tax cut in the
short term it's not a permanent tax cut
but I think you know what I'm talking
about when I say the Trump quote tax
cuts so we've had some time it's been a
little while now we're starting to get a
sense of the effect but what should we
measure to figure out whether the tax
cuts have been successful or not well I
think the most relevant way to do this
would be to look at what Donald Trump
claimed would be the effect of the tax
cuts and see if it was and the big
picture was that the tax cuts will
reduce government revenue in a sort of
short-term micro way but they are going
to cause the economy to grow so much the
economy is going to be on fire that the
tax cuts will pay for themselves and
will reduce the deficit overall so tax
cuts go down so government revenue goes
down but the tax cuts that rich people
and corporations get gets put right back
into the economy and it will trickle
down and generate so much new income and
productivity that government revenues
will actually go up and then they can
reduce the deficit and start paying off
the debt this hasn't happened okay to
make it very short for you we have a new
report from the National Association of
Business Economics 84 percent of
respondents businesses have not changed
plans as a result of the corporate tax
cut seventy five percent say they have
not nor do they have plans to increase
hiring so think about that for a second
corporate tax rate go
from 35 percent to 21 percent that's a
40% cut okay going from 35 to 21 is a
40% decrease in the corporate tax rate
eighty-four percent of businesses make
no change to their capital investment at
all the other 16 are either increasing
or summer decreasing capital investment
remember the other 16 aren't all
increasing capital investment those who
are increasing capital investment and
are increasing hiring need to now make
up for a 40% reduction to the corporate
tax rate to make this tax plan deficit
negative meaning that it reduces the
deficit obviously it wouldn't I mean
just think about this at the most basic
level if I'm a business owner and I get
a tax cut nothing else changes why do I
hire people right why do I go and choose
to increase my operating costs by adding
employees because I got a tax cut I
would hire more employees if there's
more demand for my product or service if
I have the staff to make a hundred
widgets and the demand for my widgets is
at a hundred widgets why would I go in
hire people to be able to make 200
widgets that would be a really dumb move
if all of a sudden the demand for my
product goes up to 200 widgets now I
have a reason to go and hire employees
in order to be able to accommodate that
increased demand if I get a tax cut and
nobody wants more of my widgets it would
be stupid to hire more people and the
proof is in the deficit numbers we were
told this would be so good for the
economy that we would start to cut away
at the deficit we might even start to
pay off that national debt if we ever
got to a surplus and it's all nonsense
the reality is that we learned this week
that the US Treasury is going to have to
maintain this increased level of
borrowing planning more than 1 trillion
dollars in borrowing for the second
straight year and it's partially because
of Trump's tax
guts it's partially because of other
policies all of which are increasing the
deficit
you can argue we shouldn't be so worried
about the deficit and I would agree with
you but again we are evaluating the
policy on the basis of what Trump said
it would do it's completely predictable
and it plays right into China's hands
because to finance this deficit we are
selling long-term debt called 3/10 and
30-year securities who is a big buyer of
these securities it's China Trump told
us he was going to take back control of
our economy from China and instead China
and other countries are buying our debt
so that we can finance our government
operations despite increasing deficits
which Trump told us that he would reduce
it is lose-lose-lose and the crazy thing
about this Pat is that we knew it would
happen our own government the
Congressional Budget Office told us this
is exactly what's going to happen we
knew it would happen serious economists
knew it would happen and they either
didn't care or didn't believe it and as
usual the estimates were right do you
think they even care about this reality
or have they moved on to something else
Pat I would go even further and say that
from the get-go they knew that this
wasn't going to work that the tax cuts
wouldn't just spur so much economic
growth that they would pay for
themselves I think that they weren't
arguing a good faith they just wanted to
serve their donors they want to serve
their corporate overlords and when you
think about what Trump was able to get
done legislatively in his first two
years it wasn't much she was pretty much
impotent he couldn't he couldn't repeal
Obamacare he couldn't get his wall built
but yet again he was able to get the tax
cuts passed and I think that's really
telling the normal but but but David
responses here are going to be but David
what about X company which is hiring
more people well lots of companies are
firing and not hiring despite getting
tax cuts but more importantly if the tax
cuts objectively created hiring more
than just anecdotally you would see most
companies hiring more people and hiring
depends a lot on the underlying economic
conditions which have been good for
years although they're now slowing down
but David what about X company which
gave people raises lots of companies
give raises periodically anyway others
are announcing them but are phasing them
in over multiple years many of them
would be giving raises regardless of tax
cuts what matters here is the aggregate
not individual anecdotal stories that we
can tell and the aggregate is just not
good for these tax cuts and every every
month we get more and more data to
support that hey guys if you have a dog
or a cat at home or if you're looking
for the perfect gift for somebody in
your life who has a dog or a cat check
out today's sponsor pet box a
subscription box where you can get 50%
off of your first box when you click the
link under this video and use the coupon
code Pakman when you sign up for pet box
you get an awesome selection of premium
toys all natural treats for your dog or
cat delivered to your doorstep every
month and each month the box is totally
different it's actually very affordable
when you sign up for the dog box you
tell them what size dog you have and you
get a monthly variety of true toys
rawhides bags of dog treats
and a whole bunch of other cool items
catered to the size of your dog the cat
box comes with a ton of different stuff
every month like catnip toys snacks
things for them to scratch on and almost
everything that comes in each box is
made by small family-owned businesses I
just got the dog box for my dad's
English lab named Nemo who if you follow
me on Instagram you're probably familiar
with got a bunch of cool stuff including
pterodactyl treats and a true hide thing
obviously I don't know what all these
things are called and a toy which I know
my dad is just going to love that noise
and the best thing about pet box is that
they give 10% of the proceeds to a
nonprofit called tender loving canines
which helps provide service dogs to
people with autism and to vets with PTSD
so part of your purchase goes to a
really good cause and like I said you
can get half off your first box when you
the link under this video and use the
coupon code Pakman that's PA que ma n